Олексій Гончаренко європейська
Солідарність шановні друзі от я для тих
хто вночі може нас побачити бо в інший
час не показують бо ми прирівняні до
фільмів жахів та дорослих в принципі
цього разу це відповідає ми зараз
розглядаємо тим звідтимчасової слідчої
комісії якої очолював пан Гунько слуга
народу який зараз в СІЗО значить він так
на колядував під час роботи тимчасової
слідчої комісії що зараз вже слідчі дії
відбуваються щодо нього ви знаєте мені
здається скоро нам вже доведеться
створювати тимчасову слідчу комісію по
вивченню діяльності тимчасових слідчих
комісій взагалі друзі е це перетворилося
все на тимчасове слідча заробітчанство і
ще одним свідченням цього стали просто
шедевральні слова які ми вчора почули
від голосу дуже схожого на гіганта
демократії Закарпатської на нашу зірку
Миколи Тищенко Я сподіваюсь пан Микола
тут візьми репліку і зараз пояснить бо я
ще одна тимчасова слідча комісія по
боротьбі з кол-центрами так от пан
Микола чи голос дуже схожий на нього чи
як він каже Нейро мережа може це Нейро
мережа Вона говорить що хочу 50 хочу
ресторан в Празі там куди вкласти но
саме головне щоб була константа от щоб
константа була Я розумію що раніше була
константа 10-15-20 зараз з константою є
проблеми і кожен шукає Я дивлюсь з нашої
більшості константу де може Гунько шукав
константу В аграрній академії тищенка
шукає константу він і в лісах шукав щось
знайшов Чи не знайшов тепер він шукає
константу на кол-центрах друзі ну
скільки це буде тривати ну це просто
знущання
дякуємо
[оплески]